so I wanted to do a little Twitter Q&A
with you guys so I tweeted out if
you have any questions for me pretty
brilliant right thats how it works and a bunch you
guys responded so we picked the couple
and I think we're in a few in these
but he lets get to a couple questions
that you had for me on
the Twitter Marathi to seven asked
how many now the bandwagon has joined us
Americans do you think would punch dick
cheney in the base
upon meeting him that is a good question
I am I think in the circle that I travel
in
and in the tyte circles and the most
democratic circles in progress observer
lot of punches there would be a lot of
punches I am
I think the republican
circles not so many pages I think if
I'll try to answer this seriously I do
think there's a small percentage of
people that if they just saw him
would want to attack a man that's why
and I get these guys a secret service
and all that
and project I saw the guy I wouldn't put
him I would love to talk to him
I i don't agree obviously a lot of
things and
you know he still preaching now about
what we should be doing in Iraq
when he was the architect a utter
disaster and now we're seeing the fruit
salad
and so I would still want to talk to him
and really try to get some more true
that him
really talk about how a burden and how
that all affect his decision to Mac
anything
so I wouldn't wanna punch him but I
guess amoral ever that later
there Melissa ill all said if you were
in media what career path
you think you pursue instead this was
actually kinda interesting so I studied
political science in college so I guess
I'm doing something kinda right here
I am and I remember very vividly being
in I want my classes do year and just
that professor just kept talking
about how the government just doesn't
work like it's posted now this was
probably in about nineteen ninety-seven
so our cover it was actually pretty
functional back then compared to the
insane gridlock
that we have now and he was just talking
about how the the branches are always
buy and we don't get legislation passed
that's good for the people and I talking
about money in politics and how
everything's being bought and again this
is
at this now this is 15 16 17 years ago
and
so I wanted to be a politician is the
answer to your question I'm studying
politics
and I wanted to be a politician I
remember being in the class and then
allow this thing is
so warped this thing is so warped like
how can I be a part of it
you know the and then I started thinking
maybe I was gonna do a little stand up
or something like that and then I did
stand-up comedy literally the last thing
that I was going to do in college I was
taking a public speaking class
and I'd taken all my finals I was going
home as a graduate like two days later
and I the public being that they were
and it was about summing up your college
experience
and I did a little stand up and I sat
down like bill cosby in my favorite
special
himself from a think 1983 an ideal
summation up what I thought colleges
like an half the class lap
and have class but I was not and I was
like Iran to get that make me comedian
and I went to an open mic in New York
a week later and he ran out so there you
go
next up Eric Wallace 117 would you ever
run for public office
so I was that sort of goes back to what
I was just talking about I i don't think
so I think for me my place
is talking about it I think you get to
be a lot more honest
as someone on the outside and hopefully
can influence on things and I try to be
as honest as I can and
talk about these things in a fun way
because when you watch all the shows
everybody's yelling everyone's partisan
there bought and sold
I have nobody telling me what I can say
and that's a beautiful thing and that's
why
the Internet is the future and I I think
we're at work
forcing TV maybe a to be a little more
honest
running for public office I don't think
I could do it like I think
I I think I would love the process sum
up the process of getting in there and
really negotiating things and talking
about the issues
and talking to the people but the
endless fundraising even right now as I
do this
president Obama has three fundraisers in
a in these two days
I think that a fundraiser right now in
Dallas while in doing this
so that part of it I just I wouldn't
want to do and have to sit all those
tables and listened to all the people
who are just there because they have
money I just simply don't think I could
do it so I think
my role is to to be on the outside and
talk about it and
and hopefully for me it's it
it cathartic for me and I hope because
they would have been so
so that kinda works for everybody next
up she just smoke
together that right says do you think as
long as we give credit organizations
like the Catholic Church
for their quote charities we must give
her my
the same because they both claim good
work for people
yet they both do a great deal har more
than good I would rather have neither
I you know this is this interesting
topic because you know we talk about how
religion a especially the religious
right America has dictated so much
public
policy I that's far different from Hamas
which is a terrorist organization
which is actually holding their own
people hostage and also
firing rockets at another country and so
I don't think the Catholic Church is
doing that
that being said they've done some hide
things related to women's reproductive
rights and gay rights and all that
whether churches or religious
organizations should have
tax exemption is a whole other thing I
don't really think so
they do do some good work of course but
I don't think we can really put the
Catholic Church and
at home I on the same level garden gnome
88 want to know what did do
your parents do for a living do you
think it shaped your aspirations
I so my dad worked in sales in the
garment center
and
and my mom was a stay at home mom for
most had my growing up
and then was a nursery school teacher
for many years after that she just
retire to my dad still works do I think
it's shaped me
I am you know I grew up I grew at
middle-class
in a in a very decent area I thought we
would be on the wrong side of the tracks
in the town we grew up on
but you know we we were okay and I think
that I think growing up
sorta okay a let let itself to a comedy
I because ever because most people think
they're growing up OK
even when you're not gonna be okay you
think a grown-up okay and there's some
pink bunny
about that the I always thought there
was just something a little off in the
world I don't know that it directly had
anything to do with my parents
jobs which is growing up in the suburbs
there something funny going on there
there's something weird and funny going
on in the suburbs and their
yeah I i think i it had something to do
with the path to my right now and this
is
still even though I've been due in you
know I started therapy 98 the path
you know sixteen years later still feel
like I'm at the beginning on it so it
kinda cool
alright so that is our Twitter Q&A I
think I'm gonna do this more often so
please do play along follow me at Rubin
report
let me know what you think comment yell
at me ask me questions
whatever you want to do we accept all
except racist psychotic language and
homophobic layers
met with the black ones for